so remember that tyke named Frank who
offered to cut the White House lawn for
free Donald Trump knowing a good deal
said sure it was great so that's
adorable
unless you're Steven greenhouse who
thinks it's horrible a former New York
Times writer tweets that this sick act
boosts child labour and mocks
occupational safety so while we saw a
cute kid experiencing the dream of a
lifetime this wet rag tweets out stats
on mower injuries so nothing is safe
especially fun if you're around Steven
dude must be a blast at a picnic
volleyball too many eye injuries tug of
war know all those rope blisters bobbing
for apples a child that New Zealand
drowned once but I wonder if he would
have been so panicky under President
Obama
remember he rode bikes in mom jeans he
went hang gliding he bodies surf
casually smoked I'm pretty sure that's
all riskier than a once in a lifetime
grass-cutting
but in the in the truck era everything
is extra harmful to your health
including Donald Trump Washington Post
writer Dana Millbank details of physical
where he reports suffering from chest
pains headaches high blood pressure and
blames quote trump hypertensive
unexplained disorder what he likes to
call it the thud he's joking
but once healthy now eight months into
Trump's presidency he's really sick so
is it Trump's fault of course it is but
the bright side for Milbank the
president helped him craft a cheeky
piece out of tired predictable whining
as thanks Milbank should trim the White
House edges that are wear a helmet or
mr. greenhouse will come after you it is
cute Kimberly yes it's fun you know
can't why can't somebody just let the
moment be okay that's having the time of
his life no true everything's got a risk
you know right but come on but I think
heinous child labor lemonade stands more
abuse of children and mowing the lawn
like what it's just everything has to be
something with a bad intention or
mean-spirited or abusing someone I mean
this is like the best moment of this
kids so far young fabulous life how cool
is that
and to go along with it say why not come
over and cut the grass at the White
House you know get it ready for next
year's Easter egg hunt one it's better
to cut the grass and smoke it they
should be applauding this young man well
you could wait till you're of age okay
so I just think this is fun I think it's
like Tom Sawyer or Huck them you know
what yet whitewashing the fence you know
what it's so nice it was nice there on
the other hand it's work but you know
what for me the work here is political
so I think President Trump use this
young man as a symbol of you know
industriousness and someone who wrote a
letter the White House asked if he could
come and so President Trump was sort of
you know gracious and allowing him to
come and actually do it and have this
moment but if you if you're talking
about the political power now the other
side of it is the left like Steven
greenhouse comes back and says don't
forget people do get a lot of kids I
think it's the number one source of
injuries with these devices his kids
really yes right I couldn't figure it
out there were like minor injuries but
you don't have been the hospital and
then I read one of his articles where it
was like eight toddlers that got like
fell off or shouldn't been on in the
first place kids I think gets burn their
hands
yeah they burn their yeah they put their
minor their minor things they're worse
believe me they're worse things you
could do as a kid if I was 11 and my
father said Jesse go mow the grass and I
said dad but the American the other
thing is the moral of the story you know
what you're going to go back to five
always like to say illegals are doing
the jobs and Americans won't do
he's 11 year old American citizen doing
the lawn now also I had this kid on my
show yeah Saturday and I said what are
you gonna do with all the money that
you're earning from the wait wait a
minute
did the president pan no oh he did not
that would be another man paid
internship loss but no he said I'm gonna
take the money for mowing lawns and I'm
gonna invest it in buying a leaf blower
so then I can blow leaves in the fall
the kid is a straight-up capitalist
we're all gonna be working for Frank one
day don't you
day two when you were a child you were
actually you drove tractors right how
old were you well young my cousin's the
two boys were actually a little bit more
active and they still ranch weight and
Preston Perino and Newcastle wife oh
yeah and their children are active in
helping and I remember during the Obama
administration in fact we did it on this
show they proposed through the Labor
Department these farm family rules they
were gonna put on family so that you
like my uncle wouldn't be able to say to
my cousin hey I need you to go and you
know get that got those hay bales they
were going to like detail and make them
respond to the government and thankfully
the agricultural community got together
they did the hash tag egg chat and it
got so bad that the chief of staff for
Obama promised that even if he won
reelection he would not propose this
rule anymore so families and communities
can stand up for themselves against
government intrusion it's an example
again I'm not just not seeing the
obvious it's just a kid mowing a lawn
earplug to your place I've talked about
safety but we had gloves on for the
birds people will freak out then and
make complain say it's child to be a
believe they didn't complain about the
honda lawnmower oh that's a good boy you
want to complain all right